(audience cheering)
- So it's been 30 years
since Billboard ranked
"Hold On" Song of the Year.
Was there a time in your life
that you was kind of exactly on point
you needed to hear that message?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- [All] Yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- You think so?
- No, I was really in a dark, dark space
when that lyric was written.
I was really at a point in my life
where I felt like,
I was at a crossroads and I really felt,
if I didn't get my life together
and stop do drugs
and I had a really bad
boyfriend at the time
and I just was in a lot of pain
and I just said if I
don't change my course,
I'm gonna be in a lot of trouble.
So I knew that I was at a crossroads
and that I either had to
hold on for one more day
or just die.
- [Kelly] Can I thank you
for being honest about that?
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause not everybody
is honest about that.
- Yes.
(audience applauding)
- I'm sober 15 years.
I was gonna say, I need it now,
in this world, in this time.
You need inspiration like this
and songs that can help
get you through it.
- Music heals.
- So I need it now.
- I believe music heals, yes.
- Music heals, it's true.